the 19 year old nursing student accused
of killing one person and wounding three
others at a synagogue is now charged
with a hate crime the hufadh of Poway
near san diego held a funeral yesterday
for the 60 year-old woman who died
protecting her rabbi david beg no
attended the service and he's in San
Diego David good morning John good
morning we're at the courthouse here in
downtown San Diego because the suspect
is going to be arraigned here later
today you spoke about that memorial
service we were there yesterday at the
request of the family who wanted the
media inside and we noticed that his
mourners were walking in they were
passing through doors that are still
marked with bullet holes mourners packed
the Habad of Holloway Monday to
celebrate the life of Laurie Kay there
were so many people not everyone could
get in Laurie's daughter Hannah
remembered her mom as a colorful woman
she chose to wear her mom's pink dress
my best friend her greatest advocate the
FBI now confirms they were warned about
the attack
just minutes before it happened but
didn't have enough time or information
to stop it we spoke to a man who says he
alerted the FBI after seeing the
shooters supposed anti-semitic manifesto
on the online forum in a statement the
family of suspected gunman John artist
disavowed his actions saying how our son
was attracted to such darkness is a
terrifying mystery to us to our great
shame he is now part of the history of
evil that has been perpetrated on Jewish
people for centuries
rabbi yes Roy al goldstein was one of
three injured in the shooting this was
an attack on humanity and we need to
recognize that we need to change
something we need to do something
radically different because the status
quo is not working
you know this gunman is also accused of
setting fire at a mosque last month in
this area his family says they do not
plan to hire a defense attorney for him
which means a public defender will
probably represent him and John I have
to tell you at the memorial service
yesterday the the eulogy given by
Laurie's daughter removed everyone in
the room and at one point she said to
the crowd my mother would have forgiven
her killer Wow David that's very
powerful thank you very much David